so thanks to the organizers for inviting
me this was done with when I was still
at IBM Almaden with my intern at the
time
Cameron Musco so yeah so sup linear time
low-rank approximation of positive
semi-definite matrices is the title and
let me first define the low-rank
approximation problem so we're given an
N by D matrix a think of the N rows of a
as being points in R to the D for
example a might be a customer product
matrix a I J indicates how many times
customer I purchased some item J and in
many applications a is well approximated
by a low rank matrix there might be some
underlying latent variable model or
whatever but typically a is well
approximated by a low rank matrix and
the goal is just to find a low rank
matrix approximating a so a low rank
matrix is easy to store in factored form
it has many fewer parameters you know if
it's an N by K and times a K by D matrix
I only have n plus D times K parameters
it's quick to multiply by a low rank
matrix because I can multiply a vector
first by the first low rank factor then
by the second low rank factor and really
if a is only high rank because of noise
you can think of this low rank
factorization as denoising your data so
what is a good low-rank approximation
the standard way of getting a low-rank
approximation is through the scene where
value decomposition or SVD so we call
that any matrix a it can be written as u
Sigma V where u has orthonormal columns
Sigma is a diagonal matrix with non
increasing entries as you go down the
diagonal non-negative and V is
orthonormal rows and the standard way of
getting a low-rank approximation is via
the truncated SVD so what you do is you
just take Sigma
they're decreasing as you go down the
diagonal so you just take the top K
similar values the diagonal entries of
Sigma leave them alone and zero out all
the remaining similar values this gives
me Sigma sub K and this effectively
selects the K leftmost vectors in you
and the K uppermost vectors in V this
gives me a rank K matrix which I'm
calling a sub K and so this approximates
a up to some error matrix e which
depends on all the remaining singular
values ok so why do people use the
truncated SVD for low-rank approximation
well a sub K is the best rank K
approximation for a under a variety of
different norms in particular it's the
aardman over rank K matrices B of the
Frobenius norm of a minus B where the
Frobenius norm is just the sum of
squares of entries to the 1/2 so the
issue with the truncated SVD is actually
that computing a sub K is expensive
ok so computing this exactly using the
SVD can take ND squared time if a is an
N by D matrix and we want to get much
faster algorithms than those based on
the SVD so people have been looking at a
notion of approximation for low-rank
approximation which is a relative error
notion defined as follows so the goal is
to still output a rank a matrix let me
call a prime so that the Frobenius norm
now of a minus a prime is at most
relative error 1 plus epsilon times the
best possible low-rank approximation
cost given by the SVD ok and you allow
some probability of failure and with
this relaxation you're able to get
significantly faster algorithms in
particular in work with Ken Clarkson we
showed that with this notion you can get
an algorithm which runs in time N and Z
of a where n in Z denotes the number of
nonzero entries of your input matrix a
ok so this algorithm is sin
to the sparsity of your matrix A+ what
is typically a low order term n plus d
the sum of the two matrix dimensions
times the polynomial in the rank
parameter K which is typically small and
one over epsilon for a 1 plus epsilon
approximation ok so just some
perspective even for dense matrices that
have say nd entries the SVD would take n
times d squared time whereas this
algorithm runs in only nd time and if n
is e of a is significantly less than
that like around n plus D then this
could be close to an n plus d time
algorithm okay so and stop me at any
point is there any questions let me just
go over roughly how you use a technique
called sketching to achieve these these
algorithms that run in time proportional
to the number of nonzero entries of a ok
so we're given this n by D input matrix
a and we think of the rows of a as being
endpoints here in our to the D and the
first step of these algorithms is to
choose a random matrix s and I'll
discuss just a few families of matrices
in a moment but the important property
about s is that it's a very wide fat
matrix ok so it has a very small number
of rows has roughly K epsilon rows ok
and the number of columns is N and what
we do is we compute s times a it's the
first step of the algorithm now what is
si doing is taking random linear
combinations of these end points the
rows of a in R to the D and we can look
at s times a so it's a caver epsilon by
d matrix we can think of the span of the
rows of s times a as being a caver
epsilon dimensional subspace of R to the
D which I've drawn here as a line ok so
this line represents the row span the
best times
and the next step of the algorithm after
computing s times a is to take each of
the rows of a these points and to
project the point on to s times a right
just move it to the closest point in s
times 8 ok and now I still have n points
but they're all sitting inside the row
span of s times a which is a very low
dimensional subspace of R to the D so
recall that the SVD it took number of
points x dimension squared time now I
still have n points but the dimension of
these points since they sit in this cave
or epsilon dimensional subspace is don't
you know it's only caver Epsilon so I
can afford to run the SVD now on these
projected points if I use the coordinate
representation in this low dimensional
subspace ok so that's the idea
the so one issue with this algorithm is
you can't actually afford in N and Z of
a time to project these points exactly
onto this space s times a but projection
is just least squares regression and
there are many sketching algorithms
randomized algorithms for approximately
doing projection so you can
approximately move these you move them
to an approximate closest point and the
algorithm still works ok
so this is how you get this is the basic
paradigm for applying sketching to
low-rank approximation and a natural
question here is which random families
of matrices s do you use so the first
one that might come to mind
r is a matrix of iid normal random
variables this matrix s works but
computing s times a is slow because s is
a dense matrix what Sarlo showed is
instead of choosing this random family
of matrices if you choose a family of
matrices from a much more structured
family called fast aunt and Linda's Ross
transforms then you still have roughly
kr Epsilon rows but now s times a can be
applied in roughly ND time which is very
fast it's linear in the product of the
dimensions
of your input matrix however one
drawback about this is s can't exploit
sparsity innate so if your input matrix
a has a small number of nonzero entries
you could hope to do better and what we
showed in that paper with Clarkson is
that instead if you choose s to be what
is called a count sketch matrix it has a
bit more rows than before instead of
just K epsilon rows has roughly K
squared over epsilon rows roughly but
still independent of n indeed and still
very small so it's still a wide fat
matrix but a nice property about this
count sketch matrix is that it's
extremely sparse ok so each column of
this matrix s only has a single nonzero
entry in it that entry is chosen at a
uniformly random position in each of the
n columns okay and that position is set
to be 1 with probability 1/2 and minus 1
with probability 1/2 independently for
each of the N columns okay and the nice
thing about this count sketch matrix S
is that s times a can be computed in N
and Z of a time okay so for each column
of a for each nonzero entry of that
column it corresponds to a column of s
and there's only a single nonzero entry
in that column so I can update the
matrix product s times a and you can
show that this this this approach of
using sketching for low-rank
approximation turns out to give you a
good relative error approximation with
large probability if the number of rows
the bests is an appropriate polynomial
and caver Epsilon ok so this is the sort
of the set of data this was the
state-of-the-art for using sketching for
low-rank approximation
it gives n NZ of a time recently what
we've been looking at is what I call
structure preserving low-rank
approximation so now let a be an
arbitrary n by n matrix not only do we
want a low-rank approximation
a generic low-rank approximation to a
but we also want our low-rank
approximation to have a certain
structure okay so suppose we require our
rank K approximation a prime for example
to be positive semi-definite or PSD okay
so the just the definition is that a
prime is a symmetric matrix and all the
eigenvalues are non-negative okay so now
can we can we still solve this problem
very quickly if we require this
additional property about a prime you
know this occurs PSC matrices occur all
over the place for example covariance
matrices kernel matrices laplacian x'
and your matrix a that you want to
approximate itself might not be a PSD
matrix for instance maybe it was
supposed to be a PSD matrix but because
of roundoff errors in an application
turned out to not be Pfc but still
knowing that it should be PSD you want
your low-rank approximation a prime
itself to be PSD okay so yeah so the
goal here is just to output a rank a PSD
matrix a prime for which the Frobenius
norm of a minus a prime is small to
solve this problem you can first assume
that the matrix a is actually a
symmetric matrix ok so right now this we
have this arbitrary n by n matrix we're
assuming nothing about it we just want a
reign K matrix approximating it and I'm
saying that this arbitrary n by n input
matrix we might as well assume it's a
symmetric matrix why is that well you
can write any matrix a as a symmetric
part a sim plus an anti-symmetric part a
a sim how do you do this
well the symmetric part is just obtained
by averaging the corresponding pair of
off diagonal entries a IJ plus AJ I over
2 and the asymmetric part is obtained by
taking the difference of the off
diagonal entries divided by 2 and the
important point is that an a symmetric
matrix if you think of it as a vector
it's orthogonal to a symmetric matrix if
you think of that as a vector because
you know you'll have two corresponding
entries that are equal in the symmetric
matrix but in the a symmetric matrix
they'll have opposite sign so the inner
product will be 0 and because of that if
I'm approximating a by symmetric matrix
a prime then by the Pythagorean theorem
I can write the square Rubinius norm of
a minus a prime as the symmetric part of
this matrix which is a sim minus a prime
the squared norm of that plus the
squared norm of the anti-symmetric part
of the matrix okay this is just the
Pythagorean theorem since these are
orthogonal and notice that the second
part doesn't even depend on a prime you
know the rank a matrix that you're
trying to find so any any rank a matrix
a prime that you find is gonna have to
pay the cost of this second part so I
might as well just assume that my input
matrix a is symmetric because I think
imputed symmetric part in N and Z of a
time right I just average the off
diagonal entries and now I have a
symmetric matrix okay so a is symmetric
and what is the best PSD rank K
approximation which I'm going to call a
sub k plus 2 this matrix a so if I give
you an arbitrary symmetric matrix a can
you tell me what its best rank a PSD
approximation is
if the last is no negative or the gate
one whichever one comes yeah I mean so
you use zero out all but the top k
positive eigenvalues of a and that gives
me yeah
a sub K plus okay so what is known about
this problem so an earlier work this
year with Clarkson we showed that you
can still get input sparsity time and
you can find PSD rank K matrix a prime
which has this relative error guarantee
so it's the cost is at most 1 plus
epsilon times the cost of using this
optimal a sub k plus and this
this improves several previous works so
one thing you might be familiar with is
what's called the nice rom method which
is a method which occurs in in kernel in
kernels and machine learning so this is
a very fast method but it doesn't have
provable guarantees it's based on
sampling columns of a and in order to
get provable guarantees you need to make
incoherence assumptions on your input
matrix a where as our running time
statement holds for an arbitrary a
there's also a bound by ginzan mahoney
which showed that you can find a PSD a
prime with a weaker error guarantee so
the error instead of being epsilon times
the Frobenius norm of a minus the
optimal matrix is epsilon times the
nuclear norm that the sum of the similar
values instead of the sum of the squares
which can be quite a bit larger there's
work by Wang at all that gets a bit
worse or a running time roughly N
squared K R epsilon time and has a
larger rank K R epsilon but okay so so
this is input sparsity time for PSD
low-rank approximation and so the
question is like how good are these
algorithms so so for general matrices a
there is an N in Z of a time lower bound
you have to read almost all of the
entries if you want to get a relative
error low-rank approximation now why is
that so here is a very simple example
matrix a it has a bunch of ones and it
has some zeros and one of these entries
is infinity okay and it's place at say
uniformly random position and you have
no idea where this entry is if you don't
read most of the nonzero entries then
you're not going to find this infinity
entry with large probability but if I'm
a good rank one matrix you know the
first thing I'm going to do is I'm going
to assign if in infinity to this entry
you know because I'm taking the
difference of this and a rank one matrix
I better wipe out that infinity term so
I need N and Z of a time if I want a
good relative error approximation and
you can actually show that there's also
an N and Z of a time lower bound even if
you require outputting a PSD matrix to
an arbitrary input matrix a okay
so in fact these lower bounds there even
for an easier problem of just someone
gives you a matrix a and asks you what
is the norm of this matrix I mean that I
still have to read nzv entries to find
this infinity if I don't do that I'm not
going to estimate its norm very well
okay so there's already a lower bound
for this problem so now the next
question that we had is the following
suppose the input matrix a this n by n
matrix is itself PSD alright so earlier
we're trying approximate an arbitrary
matrix by PSD matrix now we our input
itself is PSD and you know maybe we just
want to approximate a PSD matrix for
efficiency reasons the question is is
there an N in V of a time lower bound
for low-rank approximation of PSD
matrices or stepping back to this even
easier question is there an N in Z of a
time lower bound just for estimating the
norm of a PSD matrix
you might only need that I might get an
idea yeah so the diagnose very key to
this to this problem and that's the
right intuition and it turns out that
you can estimate the norm of a PSD
matrix reading roughly only order n
entries okay so let me just give you
know this will help for intuition for
the low-rank approximation so that's the
other estimate the norm of a PSD matrix
in sub linear time so I'm looking at the
squared for beanie a storm of some PSD
matrix a now a is PSD which which means
that I can write it as B times B
transpose or I can think of B as being
the square root of a this is
well-defined since a is PSD so what is
the squared for being a storm a BB
transpose that's the sum of squares of
all the entries well what is the IJ
entry that's just the inner product of
the ith row of B and the J throw would
be write the the jth column of B
transpose and looking at the sum of
squared entries okay well what do we
have so by Cauchy Schwarz let's look at
one of these entries inner product of BI
be J squared by Cauchy Schwartz this is
at most the squared norm of BI the ith
row of B times the squared norm of the
jth row of B right and what are these
entries these are the diagonal entries
of a
right so okay so suppose all the
diagonal entries of a were one just for
some intuition and what is this
statement mean
well this cauchy-schwarz is then saying
well then all the off-diagonal entries
have to have absolute value at most one
all right so now I can't hide this
infinity in an off diagonal entry
because it means that one of the
diagonally entries must also be infinity
and now let's let's suppose the the sum
of squares of the off diagonal entries
actually contributed a lot to the
Frobenius norm of a in particular was Li
the sum of squares of the off diagonal
entries was at least an epsilon fraction
of the overall for Venus norm which
means suppose it's at least an epsilon
fraction of the contribution to the
Frobenius norm on the diagonal alone
while all the diagonal elements are 1
all right that was just by assumption
this is 1 so this means that sum of
squares of off diagonal elements is at
least epsilon times n if it's not then
it doesn't matter like if we know that
sum of squares of the diagonal elements
is end every diagonal element is 1 and
if the off diagonal elements if they're
sum of squares contributes to the
overall squared for being a norm well
its sum of squares had better be at
least epsilon n if it's smaller then we
don't even need to look at the off
diagonal elements okay but now we're in
a situation where we have a bunch of
small terms all of these terms be ibj
inner product squared or at most one and
they sum up to something very large like
epsilon n so what do you do when you
have a bunch of small things summing up
to something very large
yeah so uniformly sample right so
uniformly sampling if we sample roughly
n times a polynomial and one over
epsilon of these off diagonal terms you
know we we average them and then we
scale back up by the reciprocal of the
sampling probability we get a good
feeling we get a good estimate for the
sum of squares of the off diagonal terms
so we only had a sample and off diagonal
terms and that's it so we had to order n
sub linear time algorithm so just
pictorially we were assuming the the
diagonal entries were all 1 the sum of
squares of off diagonal entries was at
least epsilon N and each off diagonal
entries at most one in absolute value
these were these two conditions and they
imply that uniformly sampling entries
gave me a good approximation to the
square root for B Gnaeus norm and
something very similar happens when the
the diagonal entries are not all equal
to one you just do important sampling
instead of uniform sampling so just
quickly define the probability pIJ of
sampling an entry IJ to be the squared
row norm of bi times the squared Rowen
OMA BJ divided by a normalization factor
this factor is the sum of squares of all
of these so notice that this probability
pIJ can be computed just by reading the
diagonal entries right this is the I
ignore entry of a this is the J diagonal
entry and this is the sum of all of them
so if I just do important sampling if I
just let my random variable X be the
squared value of the I J off diagonal
and I mean I get entry divided by the
probability of sampling it then just the
standard thing here is that the
expectation of X is the sum over all
entries IJ of the property of sampling
the entry times the squared value over a
probability of P I J this is my random
variable if I sample it and I get that
the expectation is this
where norm and I can upper-bound the
variance by this second moment and it's
just the sum over all IJ of the property
of sampling that entry times the squared
value if I sample that and now I just
use the fact this cauchy-schwarz again
like I cancel one of the probabilities
and I use kosher Schwartz to upper bound
this inner product in terms of the
squared norms of the rows and so I can
overall like you can show that the
variance is at most n times the squared
expectation so this means that if I take
you know roughly n samples I'll get a
good approximation with high probability
okay I mean with good probability okay
so pH D matrices it's possible to
estimate their norm and so the previous
lower bound strategy doesn't apply and
our main result is actually that given
an N by n PSD matrix in roughly N times
K squared poly one over epsilon time we
can output a range K matrix a prime
which achieves relative error that the
Frobenius norm of a minus a prime is at
most 1 plus epsilon times the optimal
rank a approximation cost okay so this
is much faster than these input sparsity
time algorithms that we saw based on
sketching earlier in the talk right this
is this corresponds to say of one of the
low order terms in those input sparsity
time algorithms in fact the number of
entries you read is roughly about n
times K for constant epsilon and if the
matrix exponent multiplication that the
exponent of matrix multiplication is 2
we can improve this to n times K and we
do show a lower bound that you need to
read roughly n K over epsilon entries so
at least for constant epsilon this is
roughly tight okay so let me give you
some intuition of how the algorithm
works so the starting point is a
connection to what's called adaptive
sampling and this is an algorithm
proposed by Deshpande and impala so
the idea is as follows you'd like to you
have this n by n matrix a and you'd like
to sample a small subset C of its
columns which contains this small subset
contains a good rank K space inside of
its span this is your goal and how are
you gonna do this what you do is you
start off you have no columns chosen and
you just choose a column proportional to
its squared norm that's the first step
now I have one column now I look at all
my remaining columns and I compute their
square distance to the column I've
already chosen and I sample proportional
to that square distance now I have two
columns now I take two columns and I
look at the span of these two columns
and I look at all my remaining columns
and I sample column proportional to the
squared distance of the span of those
two columns and I repeat this process
okay so I iteratively choose a column
proportion with probability proportional
to its square distance to the span of
the columns that I've already chosen
okay so that's all this is saying you
know I initialize my columns to empty
set and I repeat this process roughly K
squared of Reps long times just sampling
proportional to the squared distance
what I've already chosen that's what
this statement is saying and what they
prove is that if you do this then there
exists a K dimensional subspace V inside
of the span of these roughly K squared
over epsilon columns that you sampled
such that if I were to project my
columns of a onto this K dimensional
space so I get a rank K matrix then this
is a good rank K matrix it means that
the cost of using that rank K matrix is
that most one plus epsilon times the
optimal cost of any rank K approximation
okay so okay so this is a very simple
intuitive algorithm but there's
something very important to note about
this algorithm which is that it doesn't
look at many inner products between
pairs of columns of evade right so I
have n columns and there are N squared
pairs of columns and I could be looking
at the
a product between all N squared pairs of
these columns you could imagine
algorithms that do that this algorithm
is not doing that what is it doing it's
actually looking at a very small number
of inner products between pairs in the
first step what is it doing it's just
sampling a column based on its squared
norm well that that's that's it's
looking at n end pairs of columns like a
column with itself right because it's
squared norm is just its inner product
with itself I'm looking at n of these
the nice sample column then I want to
look at my remaining n minus 1 columns
and find their distance to the column
I've already sampled that dis involves
knowing the inner product of that column
with the column I've already sampled
that's just n more inner products now I
have two columns and now I need to know
these n minus 2 columns I need to know
their inner products with both of the
columns I've already sampled so in fact
this algorithm it only needs n times the
size of the number of columns which is K
squared over epsilon pairs of inner
products it only has to look at a very
small number of pairs of inner products
of columns of your input matrix okay so
this will be a very important property
on the next slide yes so as I just said
it looks just the algorithm only looks
at much less than N squared of the total
possible number of inner products it
could look at and so the idea I mean so
here here's one idea so again since a is
PSD we can write it as say B transpose B
and the nice thing about this is suppose
we wanted to run our adaptive sampling
algorithm on B
then a has already come and were given a
then a has already computed all the
pairs of inner products that we might
need all right a a is the matrix of
inner products of all the columns of B
so what I can do is I can just run the
adaptive sampling algorithm on B without
actually knowing B I just read the inner
products that I need to run that
adaptive sampling algorithm and those
inner products are entries of a and we
just said well we only need to read a
very small number of entries to run the
whole adaptive sampling algorithm so I
can run this whole adaptive sampling
algorithm in sublinear time roughly n K
squared over epsilon time I just use
this matrix a as an Oracle whenever I
need an inner product for a pair of
columns in B ok so this this will give
me an output a rank a approximation
which is a good low-rank approximation
to be I mean that's the adaptive
sampling algorithm that we just said
right so a is like this table of all
inner products that we might need the
problem with this though is we wanted a
good low-rank approximation to a and it
turns out that if you use this same okay
so B and a B is the square root of a B
and a have the same singular vectors so
if there's no approximation involved if
I took the best rank a space for B it
would also be the best rank a space for
a but since there's approximation
involved actually this is not
approximation preserving so you can show
that this if you use the same space
formed from that small set of columns by
running adaptive sampling on B if you
use that same space for a you can get an
arbitrarily bad approximation to a ok
you'd really have to crank down this
epsilon to be very small as a function
of the spectrum of a actually so it
doesn't quite work but what we're gonna
do is we're gonna but by the way this is
already useful in its own in the sense
that sometimes you want to low-rank
approximation to a factor of a
kernel matrix and you can think of a as
being a kernel matrix and this being a
low-rank approximation to a factory form
but that's not what we're going to do
here so we still want a low-rank
approximation of a and we'll see how B
can still be helpful in that regard
just in a different way okay
so what we're going to do is we're going
to use the notion of what's called a
projection cost preserving sketch now
this is a sample the set C of columns of
a which has the following property so
this was in a beautiful work of Michael
Kohan at all
very tragic news recently and what they
showed is the following that they define
the following notion that C is a as a
reweighed subset of columns of a which
has the following property it has a
corset like property which is that if
you give me any rank K projection matrix
P suppose I look at I minus P the
projection onto the complement of P
suppose I look at the norm of I minus P
times C then that's the same as the norm
of I minus P times a up to a1 plus or
minus epsilon factor ok so what does
this mean I have my n columns of a and I
want to compute the sum of their squared
distances to P but I don't want to keep
a around because it's too big and it
takes a lot of memory etc so I'm not
going to keep it around I'm just going
to compute this C which has a much
smaller number of columns and every time
you ask me to what is the distance to
your favorite rank a space I'm just
going to use C and compute it in terms
of C and I know that's a good
approximation to a ok so it's a corset
in the sense that it holds for every
matrix P simultaneously every projection
matrix P ok so a nice thing about
projecting cost preserving sketches or
PC peas is that if you find a rank K
projection matrix P which minimizes the
left-hand side
it also minimizes the right-hand side
right because it preserves everything up
to one plus epsilon so you know what
does that mean well it means that if
somehow someway I was able to get a PCP
for for a for the columns of a with a
small number of columns say a number of
columns which is roughly like Polly cave
or epsilon then I could just take C and
I could find its best its top K singular
vectors its best K dimensional space why
because it's best K its top casing the
vectors minimizes the left hand side and
so because it's a PCP it's also a good
one plus epsilon approximation for the
right-hand side so once I have C forget
about a I just find the top K left
singular vectors of C and I get a good
approximation for a yeah and if C has a
small number of columns I can afford to
read all the entries in C there are only
n entries in each column of C and I'll
get like roughly n poly K reps long time
so really if we can find this PCP see
also in sublinear time like roughly n
time then we're done our goal is just to
find this PCP okay yeah so how are we
going to do that so we want to sample
columns of a to build a PCP so we're
going to use a notion called the ridge
leverage scores and it's not for this
talk it's not so important if you
understand the definition but this was
introduced in several different works at
the same time similar times Lee Miller
paying capital of at all allow a and
Mahoney basically these are so there's
just some quantity for each column of a
I define a what's called a Ridge
leverage score tau sub I of a what this
quantity is is it gives a smooth version
of the standard rank K leverage scores
if you've seen these before so
yeah if you haven't seen this before
it's not it's really not important what
they are for the talk but the rank a
leverage score is what they are is if
you take the top k left singular vectors
of a matrix these these top K left
singular vectors they like if I take the
top K left singular vectors of a matrix
u sub K then I know the squared column
norms of this matrix are all one because
these are orthonormal vectors and the
squared row norms the I squared Rho norm
is called the ithe levered score the I
3k leverage score okay and these can be
arbitrary I mean they they sum up to K
since the sum of the columns is K the
sum of the rows is also K but in any
case the ridge leverage scores they're
useful as they give sort of a smoother
version of this I mean there were bus to
slight perturbations in a etc the sum of
all the rank a all the ridge leverage
scores is at most 2k so slightly larger
than K as it is here but it's still
small which is what we'll need for
sampling based algorithms and there's
some connection to Ridge regression if
you've seen it before these correspond
to the standard leverage scores of
taking your matrix a and concatenating
them with a scaled identity matrix but
again it's not so important if you
haven't seen it so how are we going to
use the ridge leverage scores so it
turns out that they provide a PCP okay
so let me say that more precisely so in
work of Cohan Musco and Musco they
showed the following suppose you have
overestimates tilde tau I for each of
your actual Ridge leverage scores tally
let's define a probability distribution
on the columns of a piece of I
corresponds to the probability for the
ith column and it's just proportional to
the 2 tilde tau of I the ice approximate
reads leverage squirt
then we're gonna sample a set C of T
columns of eight ignore for the moment
what T is but we're gonna do it with
replacement and the ithe column of C is
just going to equal the Jade column of a
with probability P sub J scaled by
roughly square root of T times the
probability that we sample that column
okay so we're sampling T columns we
scale by roughly 1 over the square root
of T times the probability that we
sample it okay the number of columns you
sample it's proportional to the sum of
your over estimates to the actual ridge
leverage scores okay so if you had the
actual ridge leverage scores the sum of
them would be K and you would sample
roughly K log K of epsilon squared
columns and yeah if you have you know
sort of crude estimates you have to
sample more but they showed that if you
sample according to this distribution
you get a PCP and we said if you have a
PCP then we're done with our problem
okay but the question is you know how do
we get the ridge leverage scores or how
do we get good approximations to them in
sub linear time okay so I mean doesn't
seem obvious how to the ridge leverage
scores are defined by some complicated
expression how can we get these in
sublinear time so what we're gonna do is
use the connection that I mentioned
earlier to this literature on on kernel
matrices in machine learning
so we said a is equal to B B transpose
since it's PSD so we can think of a as
being the kernel matrix of what's called
a linear kernel and there is work on by
Musco Musco in last year which shows how
to approximate the ridge leverage scores
of B to a constant factor in and the the
the time that you need is n times K
kernel evaluations
and now we're going to use this
connection again that one Colonel
evaluation is just an entry of a because
this is a dot product a colonel
evaluation for a linear kernel means a
dot product so there's an algorithm that
can compute the ridge leverage scores of
B each up to a constant factor by
reading only n K entries of a and what
we show is that the reads ever scores of
a are related to the ridge leverage
scores of be okay even though we said if
you're getting a good low-rank
approximation to be it could be
arbitrarily bad low-rank approximation
to a but what we do have is that at
least the ridge leverage scores a B if
we scale them by roughly root n then
they're over estimates to the ridge
leverage scores of a and okay so what is
the sum of all of our over estimates
this is the this is the tilde tau I
we're going to use it's going to be root
n over root K times the ridge leverage
score of B well we said the sum of all
the ridge leverage scores of a matrix is
roughly K and the number of columns that
we need to sample is proportional to the
sum of these approximate Ridge leverage
scores so when we sum all these up we're
going to get roughly root n times root K
and then this works it turns out that if
you sample roughly rude and root K
columns of a according to the ridge
leverage scores of B then you get a PCP
for a okay
and this PCP so so this this this
already gives us an algorithm we know in
order n time we can find all these good
approximations to the ridge leverage
scores of B then we know that if we over
sample by a root n factor if we sample
roughly root n K columns of a
proportional to these then we'll get a
subset of root n columns which is a PCP
for a and therefore we can just find the
best rank K approximation inside of
there
that already leads to an end to the
three halves time algorithm which is
already you know sub linear time for
certain values of N and Z of a the final
step which we really wanted actually an
end time algorithm what we've shown is
how to take a sample roughly root n
columns to get this matrix see there's
one other step is we show how to stamp
sample roughly root n rows of this
matrix C to get a matrix R which is root
n by root N and it turns out that
actually the sampling probabilities are
the same ones that we used for C there
again the ridge leverage scores of B and
we said we could compute those in sub
linear time very quickly but I won't get
into the details of that but the but but
the point now is R is a very small
matrix root n by root n and now you can
do whatever you want on this okay so you
can afford to run these inputs parts of
you time algorithms on R because they'll
take it most end time ok so since R is
so small you can use the earlier
sketching techniques I described to find
its top K right similar vectors since R
is a PCP for C its top K right singular
vectors can be used to find the top K
left similar vectors of C and since C is
a PCP for a its top K left singular
vectors are a good low-rank
approximation to a so that's the overall
like logic behind the algorithm like you
you reduce it to a small square matrix
do whatever you want
find the top K similar vectors then
there's a procedure of using those top
casing there vectors to find the because
our sits inside of C here so I find its
top K directions and I can actually
sample from them to get K directions
inside of C that are very good for C and
since those are very good for C they're
also very good for a because C is a it's
a good representation of a it's a PCP of
eight so overall the algorithm runs in n
K poly one over epsilon time so just to
conclude yeah we give the first sub
linear time algorithm achieving relative
error low-rank approximation for a
natural family of matrices
for PSD matrices which bypasses this nnz
of a time lower bound for general
matrices in fact our concrete bounds are
fairly tight I mean we're getting n
times K entries and that we can prove a
lower bound for that you might ask for
other error measures not everyone is
just interested in the Frobenius norm it
turns out that if you want spectral norm
error that's impossible
in sublinear time we can show that but
you can get sort of a mixed guarantee
where it's like a mixture of a spectral
and the Frobenius guarantee you output a
rank K matrix a prime for which this the
the squared spectral norm difference is
at most 1 plus epsilon times the optimal
squared spectral norm difference plus a
term that depends on the Frobenius norm
so epsilon over K times the squared for
beanie a storm of a tail that you can do
in something your time I mentioned this
earlier problem in the talked of
sometimes you want to output a matrix
which is itself PSD you want your low
rank matrix to be PSD we can do that
here too
so we're given a PSD matrix and we
output a rank a PSD matrix in roughly n
time and the open questions here so a
natural question is to get tight bounds
on this epsilon parameter our upper
bound is roughly like 1 over epsilon to
the 2.5 and our lower bound is roughly 1
over epsilon and sort of more generally
like are there other natural families of
matrices for which you can bypass you
know skirt around this nnz of a time
lower bound and get like a truly sub
linear time algorithm so that's all
[Applause]
I see so you have like your PSD matrix
plus an error matrix if it's small
enough and if you just get a in certain
cases if you get together low-rank
approximation to the PSD part is these
techniques I'm not sure how we're busted
would be in that case like certainly if
the error is small enough then I think
this should go through but I don't know
exactly what they limited that is yeah
good question yeah
[Applause]